let's talk about blood pressure
homeostasis and what homeostasis means
is balance so how is it that our body is
able to create balance for our blood
pressure so this is the heart and we've
got branches of the aorta coming off of
it I haven't been drawing these branches
every single time but this time I think
it's quite helpful to see we've got here
the left brachial artery going out to
the left arm and we've got the left
carotid artery here and again I'm
writing left and right from the
perspective of the person whose heart
this is and you've got here the right
carotid artery and the right brachial
artery so this is blood going to the
right arm and we've got blood going to
the right neck one interesting thing if
you look at the right carotid is that it
bulges right here back both sides do and
they bulge right before they split and
so that bulge is actually called the
carotid sinus right here carotid sinus
and we call it that because a sinus is
any cavity and so if this is the right
carotid sinus and this is the left
carotid sinus another spot I'm going to
talk about in this video is the aortic
arch which is right there so these three
spots the two carotid sinuses and the
aortic arch are really really
interesting and actually they're very
important for learning about how it is
that our body is able to create balance
in our blood pressure so at the top I
drew kind of a blow-up version of the
carotid sinus and at the bottom is the
aortic arch and if you look closely
under microscope you'd see nerve endings
on the outer layer of the vessel and so
these nerve endings basically join up
and form a nerve and these on the
carotid sinus do the same thing
and they are basically going to form two
large nerves that go off and they send
information about what's happening in
the blood vessel specifically about
stretch so as blood is pulsing through
this vessel right here this carotid
sinus or as it's pulsing through the
aorta even that wall is being stretched
out and as it gets stretched out these
nerves they're actually called they're
very special nerves are called
baroreceptors Baro mean pressure and
their receptors for pressure so they're
baroreceptors these baroreceptors are
feeling the effects of stretch and what
they do is they send a signal down the
nerve that tells the brain how much
stretch is happening and so if this is
the brain let's say and you have here
your midbrain midbrain these nerve
endings are going to actually go here
and tell the brain communicate
information about how much stretch is
happening in those vessels now we know
that the more pressures in the vessel
the more it's going to stretch so follow
with me in a little example so let's say
we have blood pressure here and let's
say I have my blood pressure of 115 over
75 and in green I'll write action
potentials per minute action potentials
per minute so what happens is that as my
blood pressure is 115 over 75 those
nerves are feeling a certain amount of
stretch whatever that amount is and
they're going to send a signal not just
one but they're going to send a handful
so let's say they send ten signals ten
signals I'm going to draw them out here
five six let's say seven eight
nine and ten ten in one minute
and actually let's just imagine that
both nerves are doing this right so
they're doing ten per minute well that's
a pretty normal number let's say and
this over time becomes what the brain
regards as my normal set point the brain
starts to assume that if ten action
potentials are fired per minute then
that's pretty normal for me so it
regards this is my normal set point now
if my pressure goes up let's say that
I'm running late to an exam or something
happens that you know really worries me
and my pressure goes to 140 over 90 now
I have hypertension and this is my new
pressure this would be much higher than
normal so my body would would register
this and my nerves would start firing
let's say it's 30 times per minute 30
times per a minute so if they're firing
it's 30 times per minute then my body is
thinking or my brain is thinking well
that's higher than normal so this must
be high it regards this is high and on
the flip side let's say that you know I
have um let's say I cut my arm and I
lose a lot of blood and my blood
pressure starts to fall my stretching is
going to happen less than before so it's
going to send less action potentials per
minute maybe only 7 per minute and again
my midbrain is going to get 7 little
green arrows per minute 7 you know
action potentials per minute and it's
going to think well that's very odd you
know before it was 10 per minute so this
represents a fall in blood pressure so
now you have high blood pressure in pink
and a fall in blood pressure in blue so
what exactly can the brain do what can
the brain do to help normalize or create
balance so let me write that in over
here let's write response question mark
response so the body has a couple of
strategies and they're basically summed
up in the autonomic nervous system
autonomic nervous system and there's two
major branches of your autonomic nervous
system or two parts to it let's say
parts one is called the sympathetic
sympathetics
almost like sympathy and the other is
called para para sympathetics the very
similar words except the word para is in
front of this one and I want you to
remember now that there's a formula and
I'm going to write that formula down
here just to just to remind us that
pressure equals flow times resistance
and additionally I want you to remember
that flow this work this one right here
is going to be related to stroke volume
times heart rate so if I can do anything
my body can do anything to raise a
stroke volume or the heart rate or the
resistance then my pressure will go up
and vice versa if I can drop the stroke
volume or heart rate or resistance then
my pressure will go down okay so what
the sympathetics do is they have an
effect on the heart and the the vessel
so the heart and the blood vessels and
these blood vessels are all over the
body not just not just the carotid sinus
or they are Dakar's I'm talking about
all blood vessels and so the
sympathetics are going to for the heart
they're going to increase the heart rate
and they're going to increase the stroke
volume and the parasympathetics do the
opposite they actually drop the heart
rate and drop the stroke volume and the
way that they do that the heart rate is
controlled by how
the beats you get per minute obviously
that's the heart rate and the synthetics
are going to cause the heart cells that
control that to work faster and the
power synthetics will slow them down and
for the stroke volume the sympathetic
force the heart to contract harder and
then you have more volume of blood
gushing out with every beat and the
parasympathetics make the heart work
less forcefully so you have less blood
gushing out with every beat and the
sympathetics finally they actually cause
vasoconstriction vasoconstriction and
you guessed it the parasympathetic do
the opposite so they cause vasodilation
and vasoconstriction and vasodilation
basically mean whether the artery stays
open or closes down so for the
sympathetics the arteries and arterioles
primarily mostly as the arterioles they
start to get smaller and as they get
smaller that increases resistance and
for the parasympathetics they will cause
the arterioles to get bigger to dilate
and that will cause the resistance to
fall so taking a quick peek at our
equation that I wrote out for you on the
on the right you can see that the
sympathetics basically do everything
that will help to increase the pressure
so if you have a pressure again of 140
over 90 then what will happen is your
body will see that as a high pressure
and will try to get the parasympathetics
to be active will activate all the
parasympathetic nerves and if your
pressure is low if it's 90 over 60 then
the body is going to respond by getting
all the sympathetics to react you see
how that works and of course it's your
pressure let's say is 115 over 75 and
the baroreceptors are firing you know
the usual 10 times
in it then there should be really
overall no response so here you would
really get no response because the body
is thinking well everything is already
balanced there's nothing for it to do so
this is how the body is able to control
blood pressure in a rapid way so that's
the final point I want to make that the
input here the baroreceptors these are
nerves and the autonomic nervous system
obviously these are nerves so the
information going in is the
baroreceptors the information going out
is the autonomic nervous system and all
of this is happening rapidly this is all
very rapid and when I say rapid I mean
on the order of kind of seconds to
minutes so within seconds to minutes
this response can happen so this is a
fantastic example of how your body can
take in information really quickly and
really respond quickly to help keep your
blood pressure balanced